but Chris this is amazing it culminated
last night in the Jets hiring Adam GaSe
and something that occurred to me last
hour of the six vacancies five of them
at the time they were filled the guys
who were hired those teams were
competing with no one else at that
moment the only guy who had another
suitor at the time he was hired was the
guy who's regarded as the least
qualified of the bunch
Kliff Kingsbury the Jets wanted him when
the Cardinals hired him the other five
hires at the time of the hiring there
was no one else out there but the hires
have still happened in quick quick
fashion well and they have I certainly
have and I was really intrigued I had
heard some of the same things that you
had at Kliff Kingsbury was certainly
high on the list for the New York Jets
and you know hey honestly I think the
Arizona Cardinals saved the New York
Jets by getting Kliff Kingsbury and we
talked about that yesterday I think but
you mean no disrespect to cliff Kings I
don't there's potential there I would
have not liked him to see be him and I
see him be a head coach yet I don't
think that was necessarily best for him
to reach his total top potential but
regardless I do think this is the right
hire for the New York Jets that's what
the point is here Adam GaSe has proven
that his offenses really have everything
and that of course he can work with
quarterbacks I mean he's made ryan
tannenhill look pretty good down there
in Miami he kind of reinvigorated Jay
Cutler's career when he went to Chicago
and Jay Cutler had one of the best years
of his career he was in Denver with
Peyton Manning and even the Tim Tebow
experiment and all of that he's a tough
coach whose offense has everything and
if I'm a Jets fan or a Jets person in
the organization the other thing I like
about this guy other than that he's
whooped their team a whole lot when he
was the Dolphins coach he whooped the
Jets all the time and believe he was
five and one he's not afraid of New
England and I think that should be part
of your resume he has shown that he can
give New England a tough time and I
think that should be part of any
conversation of hiring a coach in the
AFC East
you mentioned Tebow I had gaze on the
PFT p.m. podcast a year and a half ago
and he told me the story about what
happened in Denver when they decided to
go with Tim Tebow as the starter and it
was scour film of airforce and every
other run based offensive attack and put
together a new playbook on the fly to
suit the skills and abilities and cover
up the weaknesses of Tim Tebow that's
what a coach does yeah and what this
coach is now gonna do he's got Sam darn
'old a budding franchise quarterback a
guy that we saw great things out of late
in the year you will see gates
immediately
lock on to Sam Donald promote him defend
him right encourage he will make him
into the guy he will be Joe Namath in
the eyes of Adam GaSe and then the
challenge will be Ford Arnold to become
Joe Namath but gates will do everything
in his power to make Sam darn 'old into
Joe Namath yeah agreed I think it's like
a that the thing I like about Adam GaSe
it's a little Bruce Arians this way just
because he really you know I don't want
to say becomes buddies with the
quarterbacks but he makes the
quarterback feel like he's in the fight
with you you know that we're doing this
together and if things go bad he was a
staunch defender of Ryan Tannehill at
times when people were getting on top
yeah you're right but but at times you
know he was right like let's say two
years ago when Tannehill was playing
against the Cincinnati Bengals on a
Thursday night and they couldn't protect
anybody and they'd all these offenses he
said we got off into issues I have
offensive issues it's not Ryan Tannehill
let's everybody back off that so that is
great news for any quarterback to know
you have a coach that's going to defend
you and not always make the good and the
bad about you and I do think he will be
a great fit for for a Sam Donald his
offense has everything you want in and
as a play caller and he can adjust to
people's talents on the fly which I've
always been impressed with as well only
a small handful of quarterbacks can be
that John Wayne type of a leader if the
guy isn't naturally wired to do it it is
incumbent on his coach to make him that
guy best example of that not happening
Kirk Cousins in Washington right how do
you expect the locker room to respond to
Kirk Cousins as a leader if you're not
going to make a financial commitment to
him if you're not going to stand up and
tell anyone who will listen this is our
guy not this ambivalent one year at a
time crap this is our guy
and I think the same thing is happening
with cousins in Minnesota who
pushing back against the narrative that
Kirk Cousins isn't really all that good
does Mike Zimmer do that did he spend
any time last week at his end of season
press conference pointing out that Kirk
Cousins is our guy he's phenomenal he's
the future we were behind him a thousand
percent he is great it's on us to be
great around him no and that's what you
need if you're not wired to be Peyton
Manning Tom Brady Russell Wilson who etc
right you need your coach to push that
and that's what Gates will do with darn
'old and with a young quarterback he may
pulled Arnold into that natural
leadership role yeah I think that's a
very valid point and and you know he's
he's a no-nonsense guy too I mean I
think that's the thing I've liked he
doesn't make excuses for himself or his
football team you know even at the end
of the year when people were talking
about you know what about this in your
team and he just you know his hats
pulled down low who cares who cares what
they say we lost you know I think his
demeanor is going to go well over here
with the New York Jets as well and the
other thing I'll say is this you know
the New York Jets had they ever hired an
offensive mind unco as a head coach I
mean this is the first time we've really
seen this you know you I was thinking
about this and I pulled up the list of
hires from the New York Jets and I said
okay let's go through this whoa okay
it's Bill Parcells defensive coach
Belichick for if de defensa coach
defensive coach Herm Edwards defensive
coach Mangini
defensive coach Rex Ryan defensive coach
Todd balls defensive coach so we have
finally broke that you know run of
defensive coordinators and got a
different kind of feel and genre in the
Jets organization and I think it's the
proper time with the young quarterback
in Sam Donald who certainly showed a lot
of big time potential towards the end of
the year when he got healthy and made
some plays one last point on gays cuz we
got a lot to jam into this segment yeah
there's been this narrative that that he
benefited from Peyton Manning because he
just rode sidecar while Manning
controlled everything in Denver listen
first of all Manning reportedly called
jet CEO Christopher Johnson and made a
pitch for gays secondly Manning
wasn't gonna tolerate an offensive
coordinator can't keep up with exactly
up with him yes a state when when when
Manning wanted gays gays was there they
challenged each other they pushed each
other and somebody explained to me
recently that when you're dealing with a
franchise quarterback what you have it's
this give-and-take relationship where
sometimes the quarterback makes a throw
that makes the coach look good and other
times the coach comes up with a play
that results in an easy throw easy
touchdown that makes the quarterback
look good right that's the symbiosis
between coach and franchise quarterback
and GaSe has been through it with
Manning with Cutler that weird year with
Tebow not that he was ever a franchise
quarterback yeah trying to prop up a Ron
tan everything I think is is working in
the right direction and moving in the
right direction for the Jets now other
than the fact that we've got 50 years of
futility big picture in New York
I think gays if the fans aren't gonna
like it but you know what Eagles fans
didn't like Doug Peterson when he was
hired three years ago yeah well what did
they want that's the other thing I'd say
about this I mean tell me some better
options Jets fans I mean again to go
back to the point with defensive coaches
this is the first coach since Bill
Parcells that's actually been a head
coach before that's taking over for the
New York Jets all these other guys were
first time head coaches and I don't
think there was that many great great
candidates out there that were proven on
the offensive side of the ball in the
NFL and I think your point about Peyton
Manning is very real because if he
couldn't keep up with Peyton Manning
Peyton Manning would have exposed him
somehow some way and I know that
relationship had a great give-and-take
and Peyton Manning would give Adam GaSe
you know projects as he's leave the
building at night and go you know
tomorrow morning I want to know the
answers to these these things when when
you're studying film all night and ba ba
ba and gays always delivered case even
tinkered with the offense knowing man I
got an older Peyton Manning here who
can't throw the ball down the field as
much and they became masters at wide
receiver screens and pick plays and
things like that so again playing to the
strengths of the quarterback is a great
reason why you hire a guy like Adam GaSe
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports